- [Narrator] Hey, I'm gonna let you in
on a little secret of mine.
I love gardening.
In fact, I have a huge garden with apples,
blueberries, pumpkins, and tomatoes.
I give my plants micronutrients,
and maybe some fertilizer.
But I don't give them food in the same way
that I would give my dog who
eats multiple times a day.
With plants, I just put them in the soil,
water them regularly, and watch them grow.
How do they do it?
Well, they use a process
called photosynthesis.
Photosynthesis is a
scientific term to describe
how certain living things
use energy from sunlight
to live and grow.
Many different kinds of plants, algae,
and various single-celled
organisms are able to carry out
this amazing process.
Today, let's describe
photosynthesis using tomatoes.
So here you see a young tomato plant,
similar to the ones I
have in my own garden.
Let's name it Planty.
First, let's start off
by looking at Planty's
immediate surroundings.
The soil Planty is
growing in contains water
and the air surrounding
Planty contains molecules
of carbon dioxide.
These two compounds are the
starting materials or inputs
that Planty needs in order
to carry out photosynthesis.
Now, let's take a look
at the weather forecast.
Well, it looks like it's
gonna be a sunny day today.
So when the sun shines on the earth,
it sends out energy in the form of light.
This energy is essential for Planty
to be able to carry out photosynthesis.
Next, let's take a closer look at Planty,
because Planty's cells are
hiding a secret of their own.
Inside Planty's cells are
microscopic structures
that help Planty carry out photosynthesis.
These structures are called chloroplasts.
Chloroplasts contain
green pigment molecules
called chlorophyll.
It is actually within these molecules
that the sun's energy is captured for use
during photosynthesis.
Interestingly, chlorophyll
is where leaves get
their green color.
To help you remember, think
of chlorophyll like this:
chloro means green and phyll means leaf.
So when you put them
together, you get green leaf.
Okay, so now we know that
carbon dioxide, water,
and sunlight are required
for photosynthesis to occur.
And we know that in plants like Planty,
photosynthesis happens in the chloroplast
with the help of chlorophyll.
Next, let's take a look at what happens
during the process of
photosynthesis itself.
When the sunlight reaches
Planty's chloroplast,
its energy is used to rearrange the atoms
in the carbon dioxide and water molecules
through a series of chemical reactions.
The outputs of these reactions
are oxygen molecules and sugars.
These sugars are vital
to Planty's survival
because they are used as a
source of chemical energy
that helps Planty live and grow.
In other words, they're Planty's food.
Planty can do a few things
with the sugars made
during photosynthesis.
It can break the sugars down
to get usable energy right away,
or it can store the sugar
molecules for later use.
If Planty stores the sugar molecules,
it can then use them as a
source of energy in the future.
This means that Planty can grow
even when the sun isn't shining.
Planty can also use the sugar molecules
to build larger molecules
such as cellulose
that make up the structure
of Planty itself.
In this way, Planty can
grow bigger and bigger
with very little help from me;
all thanks to the process
of photosynthesis.
Planty's other output, oxygen,
is released into the atmosphere.
This is really cool because
it provides organisms
in the ecosystem,
including us, with oxygen.
So thanks Planty and other
photosynthetic organisms
for giving us the oxygen
we need to breathe.
And that, my friends, is photosynthesis.
So next time you're in a garden,
I want you to think about this.
All the plant structures you
can see, such as stems, leaves,
and even the fruits and
vegetables that we eat
are made up mostly of the
atoms that were once a part
of the starting materials
of photosynthesis.
With the help of a little sunlight,
the plants made their
own food and grew bigger,
taking CO2 out of the atmosphere
and releasing oxygen back
in for us to breathe.
And on that note, I
think I should go outside
and give my own garden some water.
See you later.